hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ich war mal wieder auf ebay
unterwegs um einige verkäufer zu trinken
und zu verarschen und als allererstes
habe ich da ein gut erhaltenes
didgeridoo entdeckt habt mir allerdings
gedacht und genscher sieht auf dem
baseballschläger und er schreibe ich
einfach mal meinen sohn will baseball
spielen lernen aber er kann es noch
nicht gut würden sie jetzt erstmal für
ihn auch für 15 euro verkaufen das ist
kein basketball
da ist selbst die verwirrung verwirrt
hier hat jemand in den angeboten titel
geschrieben schuhe verkauf und ich habe
daraufhin geschrieben ich will keine
schuhe verkaufen
es fällt dem einfach zu fordern dass man
schwul verkaufen soll das hier ist das
nächste produkt was sie mal auf ebay
verkaufen wollte und ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich frage mich in erster linie
warum man so was überhaupt besitzt
es einen kleiderhaken
ich habe dabei auf jeden fall nichts
gedacht und habe dementsprechend einfach
mal gefragt wo haben sie denn das schöne
tier erlegt
steht hier weil ich zu tun wollte als ob
ich hab' ich dachte dass das eine echte
blockiert als nächstes hat hier jemand
ein verrate mädchen inclusive helm
verkauft und ich habe daraufhin
geschrieben ich will bitte nur das
fahrrad und nicht das mädchen
unheimlich witzig dankeschön
hier hat jemand ein burger versus pizza
das duell verkauft und ich habe ihm
daraufhin einfach die antwort gegeben
ich mag lieber pizza der nehme ich das
schon fragt burger versus pizza dann
antworte ich halt auch
ich wurde angemeldet als nächstes hat
hier jemand ein feuerzeug verkauft wo
draufsteht weltbester feuerwehrmann und
ich mit meinen sprachkenntnissen habt
ihr natürlich erst mal geschrieben wird
weltbester nicht zusammen geschrieben
ich würde immer das hier empfehlen da
denn als nächstes habe ich auch wie wir
jemanden gefunden der ein deko schild
gekauft hat auf dem hahn ii steht so
hohen ich auf englisch von daher habe
ich geschrieben ich verkaufe in meinem
laden keinen hohen ich finde es aber als
dekoration gut kann man schön trotzdem
aufhängen hanno davon gehe ich aus hier
war der ursprung auch gedacht als
schätzchen darling ach so eine frau habe
ich aber nicht aber wenn es gefällt ist
es ja egal wo ich
hier verkaufte jemand eine neue bluse
gold in der größe m ich habe daraufhin
geschrieben wie viel karat hat die bluse
ist ein logisches imposant gold besteht
muss man irgendwie waschen können er hat
das ist nicht so ganz geschickt den
hunger und hat daraufhin geschrieben die
bluse ist nur eine gold optik hast du
trotzdem interesse meine frau markt nur
echtes gold habe ich daraufhin
geschrieben würde den versand schenken
wenn du sie nennst ja der wir dir auf
jeden fall sehr dringend loswerden hat
jemand auf ebay verkauft dass er dir zu
hören daraufhin hab mich geschrieben
danke dir endlich jemand hallo gerne nur
reden magst sagt mir einfach bescheid
ich habe sie dann angerufen drei stoffe
miteinander geredet morgen heiraten wir
das hier ist das nächste produkt das ich
entdeckt habe und zwar dort jemand einen
kühlschrank magneten mit der aufschrift
nicht vergessen verkauft und ich habe
daraufhin gefragt was soll ich nicht
vergessen dass morgen silvester ist
aber das frage ich mich wirklich nervös
den kühlschrank magneten wo draufsteht
nicht vergessen
was denn hier hat jemand ein sofa
verschenkt und ich dummkopf habe darauf
natürlich geantwortet wie viel wollen
sie für das sofa haben hab dann damit
gerechnet dass er halt schreibt 0 euro
es steht doch im titel aber nein er hat
geschrieben 20 euro
20 ist mir ein bisschen zu viel
warum schreibst du zum verschenken -
dann doch für 20 euro anbietet als
nächstes hat hier jemand einen puppen
bett auf ebay verkauft und ich habe
daraufhin geschrieben meine töchter fünf
und acht jahre wünschen sich schon
länger ein stockwerk meinen sie das
würde klappen was heißt denn klappen sie
können das für 22 euro kaufen und
abholen liebe grüße ob das passen würde
es ist ein puppen bett dafür passt es
nicht für ihre kinder wenn sie das
meinen eine baby born passt liebe grüße
ja
das war ja auch der job hier verkauft
jemand eine neue mit drei ausrufezeichen
jb elbaz studio 2.0 soundbox und ich
habe auch in gefällt ist die eigentlich
neu weil das ja so fett in den titel
geschrieben hat und daraufhin einfach
davon ja noch verschwitzt hätte diese
leute die alles mögliche meinen titel
reinschreiben auch bei amazon das ist
immer ganz schlimm da willst du einfach
nur eine nadel kauf ansteht dann neue
nadel supergeil perfekte häkeln nadeln
kosmetika wo wir haben es verstanden ich
bin ein fan ohne nadel haben
ich habe entschieden hatte lieber an
hier verkaufte jemand auf jeden fall
einen weißen sessel auf ebay und ich
habe auch viel einfacher fallen welche
farbe hat der sessel
offensichtlichen job weil es im titel
steht aber nee der ist komplett weiß
kommt eventuell wegen nicht
verhältnissen nicht so richtig rüber
danke das noch mal erklärt hast hier
wird ein playmobil feuerwehrboot
verkauft und ich habe daraufhin
geschrieben wurden mit dem sanitäter bot
schon sehr stark verletzte menschen
transportiert ja
verletzungen beinbrüche kiefer brücher
das ganze prozedere schlimm schlimm
lieber bis der erste immerhin ironischen
humor in diesem video gecheckt hat
machen wenn du allerdings hält weiter
mit dem nächsten lieber face und zwar
verkauft hat jemand eine spiel kassette
videospiel und ich hab einfach mal
gefragt welches videospiel ist das hält
egal
das ist genauso wie wenn ich sagen ich
verkaufe hier der dvd
und du denkst du einfach nur soja und
was ist da jetzt drauf wo wir allerdings
gerade schon ein thema videospiel wenn
meine lieben frau in matt schwarz das
noch nicht kennen solltet dann werde ich
euch das jetzt erst mal ganz kurz
vorstellen das ist ein mega geil das
handyspiel den man online gegen seine
freunde oder in meinem fall er gegen
fremde in turnieren spielen kann weil
ich hab keine freunde hat dieser
gameplay-szenen könnt ihr allerdings
erst mal kurz sehen wie das spiel
überhaupt aufgebaut ist und funktioniert
und übrigens gibt es zudem auch coole
booster wie beispielsweise doktor color
oder little dragon das ziemlich süß
match masters und ich haben uns dazu
entschieden dass wir vom 20 bis zum 30
januar ein turnier stattfinden lassen
bei dem die besten spieler ein iphone 13
gewinnen können diejenigen von euch die
sich über meinen link der unten in der
infobox steht die app downloaden die
registrieren sich automatisch für das
turnier und der beste spieler mit den
besten score gewinnt dann am ende ein
iphone 13 außerdem werden gewinne dann
auch noch mal auf der offiziellen
instagram seine form etwas verkündet
also schaut doch mal vorbei und jetzt
los spielen denn dann könnte vielleicht
einfach 19 gewinnen viel glück aber
jetzt geht's einfach weil dabei verletzt
denn hier wird eine wanduhr verkauft mit
einem crazy doch drauf und ich habe
daraufhin gefragt was hat er denn wie
meinen sie das liebe grüße du hast
hingeschrieben crazy dort deswegen
dachte ich der ist verrückt er wohnt
oder so
wir werden zwei tolle keramik äpfel in
der farbe apfelgrün verkaufs und ich
habe daraufhin geschrieben wie würden
sie das grün von den äpfeln beschreiben
wie die apfelsorte die ließ
den sinn von
hab ich noch nie so richtig verstanden
hier wird ein weißes longboard aus buche
verkauft und ich habe daraufhin gefragt
ich bin gegen bucher allergisch würde
das ein problem darstellen da wo ich
auch einfach blockiert chillig danke
bronco ich ebenfalls blockiert wurde ist
bei dieser nachricht hier und wartet
jemand schlüsselanhänger mit
einkaufstipps verkaufe ich hab einfach
ganz recht gefragt für zehn euro kann
ich doch auch einfach einen euro beim
einkaufen nutzen oder reha
warum brauche ich so ein ding
zum reinschieben wieder rausnehmen für
10 euro
es ist macht null sinn weil der bleibt
man sich doch auch nur die verkauft
jemand dass mia and me spiel und ich
habe daraufhin gefragt wer ist mia ein
fragezeichen zurück geschickt bekommen
und wird dann ebenfalls blockiert
irgendwann habe ich einfach alle ebay
nutzer in deutschland blockiert so dass
ich einfach nichts mehr kaufen kann bei
diesem nächsten ebay fällen wurde ein 50
jahre alter sessel verkauft und ich habe
daraufhin geschrieben schon sehr alt
gegen die bald in rente
irgendwie schon 50 jahre alt sind
daraufhin hat er dann einfach nur riesig
langen text geschrieben von wegen dass
das leder von anhalt weiß und blabla und
natürlich auch keinen bock mehr ist
werde ich euch jetzt auch nicht ein
blendendes yoga entspannung bei diesen
letzten liebe empfehle ich euch heute
vorbereitet habe verkauft die man wasser
fässer mit einem fassungsvermögen von
1000 litern und ich habe daraufhin
einfach gefragt welches lebensmittel ist
drin
ich dachte er schreibt dann irgendwie
das wasser drin oder so aber ich wurde
tatsächlich auch blockiert
wir können diese ebay feld reihe
eigentlich luca wird blockiert